yes okay next one so welcome to the
second talk uh this morning also virtual
uh by udon chang from uh cornell
in the ior department uh he will tell us
something about the local
minimals in the gaming model
please
great thanks a lot and good morning
everyone
thanks a lot to the organizer for
inviting me to this amazing workshop
it seems like you guys are having fun in
berkeley's i wish i can be there in
person
um so today i'm going to
talk about
k-means and mixture models but i want to
start with a slightly
broader perspective in terms of
non-comics optimization
um so so we know that in many machine
learning and statistics problems uh we
need to solve non-convex optimization
problem and the standard
standard theory gives us a pretty
pessimistic picture of this kind of
problem we know that if you run an
iterative algorithm like gradient
descent it is only guaranteed to convert
the local minimum
and in general there are many local
minimum in this kind of problem and most
of this local minima are a bad local
minimum in the sense that they are far
away
from the global minimum or far away from
the true parameter that we are trying to
estimate
and all these are true
in general in the worst case but um
for machine learning and statistical
problems we are usually not solving
worst case problems we are solving
problems that are constructed from data
so we'd like to know can we say more
about this kind of long commerce problem
beyond
what the standard theory says
and what i hope to convince you today
is that there is indeed
more to be said
for example
even though the original problem may be
non-comics
sometimes you can eliminate this
non-comics pro at this local minima
by conversifying the problem by say
developing a convex relaxation
i think many people
in this workshop has worked on this
approach
and sometimes even though the problem
is non-convex we can show that all the
local minima are global minima there are
no bad ones
and sometimes
for more complicated problems
bad local minimums do exist
but sometimes they have rich hidden
structure that may be made that may
guide us towards the global meaning
and sometimes
if you run a greedy iterative algorithm
somehow they can avoid the bad local
minima and converse the good one
so
in the rest of this talk i'm going to
focus
on
the middle two bullet points
and
uh present some results along these two
lines in the context of mixture models
so i'm going to tell you some of our
recent work there are examples
for
a non-convex problem having no bad local
minimum or having bad local minimum that
possess rich structures
and the work i'm going to present
involved many of my amazing
collaborators and students and
especially wei chen
who was my
former phd student who graduated last
year
right so i guess for
the audience today
everyone knows what a mixture model is
but just to make sure we are all on the
same page
i'm assuming that i have ended the
points that i generated iid
from a true mixture a true probability
distribution with density function f
star
where f star f star is a mixture of
k components
where each component is f s straw
and
just for simplicity i assume that the
mixing weights is one over k they are
all equal
but i'm happy to talk about the
generalization to non-equal mixing
weights
offline
and as a well-known example we have the
mixture of gaussian model where each of
this component is just a gaussian
density with mean theta s star
and varying sigma squared
and again just to make things simple i
assume that the variance
is known and they are the same across
these k components so the unknown
parameters are these k
centers of your gaussian distributions
and a closely related problem is the
mixture of linear regression
so here each data point is a pair zi and
yi
where zi the covariates are just purely
random
and your yi is generated from one of k
linear models
where each of this linear model is
parametrized by
theta star
and we don't know which linear model
generates which data points all we know
is the covariate and the output y
and finally a more general model that
generalizes this previous two models is
called mixture of concave distributions
where i assume that each of your mixture
components fs start has a log concave
density the log of the density is
concave in the parameter theta and star
and
this
family of block concrete distribution
includes many of the distributions that
you may be familiar or unfamiliar with
including gaussian laplacian
logistic etc
so
given the data generated from one of
these mixture models our goal is to
estimate these k parameters
that defines the
the mixture components
so this is a standard parameter
estimation problem
and
the method to go is the
maximum likelihood estimation approach
where you try to minimize the negative
log likelihood
uh that is uh computed over
uh your data points and in the special
case of gaussian um your you can
explicitly write down your negative like
which looks like this it involved this
lost some abs function
and if you take this this variance
parameter to
to zero then you can see that this lost
some epsilon function converges to the
minimum function so this gives us the
objective function
that we use in k-means clustering
where i'm trying to find k cluster
center status theta s
and assign each data point to the
closest center
and i want the total square distance to
be as small as possible
and if you just
stare at this two objectives function a
little bit it's easy to see that they
are both non-convex because they involve
a sum inside the log or it will have a
minimum
of quadratic functions
nevertheless even though they are
non-commerce you can still
run your very iterative algorithm
on this kind of objective like grading
descent it's easy to compute
the subgradient or gradient of this
function then it just take a step in the
negative gradient direction
also very popular formation model is the
em algorithm expectation maximization
where you
alternate between the e-step and the
m-step and it's not too hard to show
that e-m is actually closely related to
gradient descent in the sense that
it is just creating descent where the
step size depends on your coordinates
and finally for k-means clustering um
the standard algorithm is the lloyd's
algorithm
where you
alternate between
assigning each points to the closest
center and then updating the centers as
the mean
of the points in that cluster
so all these algorithms are standard
they are well known they exist for a
long time
and you can apply them to
to to end to a mixture estimation
problem
and the question is what is their
performance
and i think it's fair to say that
um our understanding of their
performance is still
relatively limited
um if you try this algorithms
immediately you can see that when they
work they work really well
for example here i'm trying to estimate
the centers of a mixture of four
gaussians
um
if you run gradient descent you convert
your magically
to the true centers
and if you run em it converges even fast
however sometimes they do not work
sometimes they convert the wrong centers
and the estimation error will remain
bounded away
from zero
even if you keep running the algorithm
even you have many many data points
and
again
i think
it's important to understand
when they work and when they
don't work
and there is a long line of work
on mixture models coming from both the
statistics and the machine learning
complex science literature
a majority
of the resources are symptotic in nature
assuming that the sample size goes to
infinity and moreover they typically
typically focus on the property of the
global minimum
but do not say how you find the global
minimum we only assume that we already
found
find the global minimal solution
and and in more recent work we started
to see some finite sample results
but this kind of result often assumes
that you run gradient descent or em
starting from a good initial solution
that has already closed
uh to the true parameter of the to the
to the global minimum
and they typically assume that the
components are well separated
and you can see that even this kind of
results are pretty reason just a few
years old
and in the
machine learning income the science
literature there is a lot of hardness
results
it's not too surprising to see that most
of these problems are empty hard in the
worst case
and in fact
for some of this mixture problem you can
explicitly prove that bad local minimum
do exist and gradient descent or em will
converge to this bad local meeting
on the more algorithmic side there are
many many heuristics many many
algorithms that have been proposed
some of them have theoretical guarantees
including those that based on special
methods tensor measures
moments methods we saw some of this kind
of work in this workshop
um
but uh in in in this talk i'm going to
focus on the simplest possible algorithm
i would say for this kind of problem
which is based on either gradient
descent or em this kind of iterative
greedy algorithms
and i'm going to present some results
that
combine tools from both statistics and
from machine learning and computer
science and optimization and hopefully
we can get a better understanding of the
performance of this this kind of
algorithm
for non-commerce problem
by estimating mixture models
all right so uh i'm going to talk about
two sets of results
for the remaining of my talk so in the
first part i'm going to focus on the
simple setting
where i only have two components in my
mixture model
and i'm going to show that
even though the problem is non-convex
all the local minimum are in fact global
minimum
i'm giving you the punchline here
all right so as i mentioned
uh i'm thinking about mixture of two
gaussian so make sure of two linear
regressions
uh where uh these two components are
parameterized by these two
unknown parameters with the one star and
fit the two star that we're trying to
estimate
and
we are looking at the negative
likelihood
function
of this problem
and our first result is about the
landscape of this long convex function
of the negative plot likelihood
and it turns out we have a pretty
precise characterization
for the staging points
for the negative likelihood l and in
fact we can show that there are in
general exactly five staging points
uh in particular um
there are two local minima
uh which correspond to the true
parameters theta one theta one star and
for the two star
or a permutation of it
so these are
here the two
uh local minima that's symmetric to each
other and from the picture you can see
that this around this local minima the
function is actually strongly complex
another staging point is a local maxima
which is here
that is in the middle of this two local
minimum
and in addition
there are two other saddle points that
are here
or here
so this set of points are orthogonal to
the two local minima
and you can you can further show that uh
this
these two set of points have
a hessian with a strictly negative
eigenvalue so there is a descent
direction
so even though the problem is non-convex
when you only have two components you
can show that
in fact all local minima are growing
minimum because we only have these two
local minima that correspond to the true
parameters
and
as an immediate
consequence
you can show that eem and gradient
descent will converge to this
global minima asymptotically starting
from any inside station
there is a climbing question yes yeah so
what's the difference to the results of
xiu and syria malaki we studied the
landscape of these two component things
yes i talked about that in two slides
and also the paper of may and by
montenarie studied the final example
version of this as well right yes yes
i'll talk about that
just in a moment
and the second question is this first
order method
is it clear they they will
uh converge to the local minimum
how do you deal with the saddle point
um i think there is existing result that
says that if you initialize randomly
then with probability one it will
converge to a local minimum it will not
converge to a set of one
but this is not a sympathetic result it
doesn't tell you how long it takes to
converge
thanks
all right so to answer that question
more questions from chris
so uh i just wanted to confirm that the
saddle points are the ones where both
centers are in the same place
on one side or the other
uh the saddle points are here and here
so this is uh
yeah but the the meaning of the saddle
points is that the uh
is that both estimated centers are in
the same
they coincide at one of the two centers
of the gaussians or whatever right
that's what's happening
um so if you if you've returned them
slightly
then one of them will jump over to the
other center
all right
so it's more like the true centers are
here right
and the set of points are here
and here
um okay i think we're talking past each
other but i
yeah
um
the local maximum is in the middle of
the two true centers no i understand the
figure
i just mean that imagine that we had two
a mixture of two
one-dimensional gaussians
and that we're estimating the centers of
those
gaussians i see in one dimension you
don't have this set of ones
okay
if that makes sense
but back to the question of convergence
rate
at least for this kind of mixture model
we have explicit characterization
of the conversion rates we can show that
from any from random initialization then
with high probability within descent or
em will converse to each non-optimal
solution of your negative log likelihood
in a logarithmic number of steps so you
have this kind of uh
geometric like convergence rates
and um so
earlier question is about the
relationship to this previous results
from
uh on the mixture of two gaussians so
uh they're special cases of this more
general model where we have a mixture of
log concave
uh distributions
um
and so in this sense we generalized the
results but i also want to highlight
that um the analysis for this monitoring
setting is actually more challenging
and
there are two types of challenges uh
when we look at this more general model
this first one is what i call
non-contraction in l2
so if you look at the mixture of
gaussian
landscape
the function actually looks like this
which is a little bit different from the
picture we just saw so in this function
we have the two local minima here
and here
and we only have one other stationary
point which is here
which is a set of one
and by looking at this picture it's not
too hard to see that if you
run grading design from any initial
solution
it will converges in a monotonical way
in terms of the distance between your
iterates
and your global solution
and a lot of existing analysis actually
rely on this monotonicity in terms of
the l2 distance
but this property does no longer hold
for the module model
uh of log concave mixture or mixture of
linear regression where the picture
actually looks like the one on the right
so you have two other
stationary points in addition to this
local maximum
so if you start your algorithm from
somewhere near the local maximum
it's not hard to see that it will first
go towards the saddle point
and then
to the global minimum
so if you look at the l2 distance
between your
and
iterates
global maximum over minimum solution
this elder distance will first increase
when you go from the maximum to the
settle point and then decrease so we no
longer
have the monotonicity property
and this makes many of the system
an analytical technique not not directly
applicable to this more general problem
and our key observation for going around
[Music]
this challenge is to look at a different
metric not the l2 distance but we should
look at the angle
between
your iterates and the true parameter and
it turns out even though the
distance does not
decrease metabolically the angle that's
and another challenge that we encounter
is about the random initialization and
the first few iterations
of your algorithm it is well known that
if you choose your initial solution
phase zero randomly it is going to be
nearly orthogonal uh to your two tr from
the theta star especially in high
dimension
so if you look at
your algorithm
and even if you are looking at the angle
or the side of the angle
the first few iterations will be very
slow
you will see virtually no progress
in the first third iteration here
even if you are looking at the echo
and again our observation here is that
you should look at
this problem in the right metric in the
right perspective
in particular in the first few
iterations it actually makes more sense
to look at the cosine of the angle
not the sine or the angle itself we
should look at the correlation between
theta 0 and theta star rather than the
angle between theta 0 and theta star
and if we do it that way then we can
prove that
we have convergence in three places
where in the first phase the cosine of
the angle actually increases very
rapidly geometrically as i'm showing
here
in this record
and after a while
once your correlation
is large enough it's close to one then
your cosine will store but your sine
would start to decrease geometrically
and then after a few more iterations you
would enter this local contraction basin
where now the l2 distance starts to
decrease monotonically
so of course altima 3 the cosine and psi
are equivalent in the sense that
the sum of the squares are one
but here i'm trying to highlight that
it's actually
more convenient or more important
to look at the right metric in order to
see this rapid
geometric convergence
and i also want to highlight that this
behavior
seems to be actually quite common
um this non-contraction increasing
distance
the contraction in some other metric
like angle and this geometric
convergence in different phases uh can
also be observed in other non-commerce
problems like matrix estimation
or phase retrieval or even positive
gradient descent
policy grading methods for reinforcement
all right so
um
so this is for mixture of two components
so things are
uh behave very nicely we have a
non-comics problem but there are
actually no bad local minimum
so for
the second part of my talk i'm going to
go beyond two components and look at
more general mixtures so here you will
see examples where battle of minimum do
exist
but
it turns out to have some rich hidden
structures
and in particular let's just focus on
gaussian mixtures but with more than at
least three components
and a very nice paper by xi jin at all a
few years back
rigorously proved that there are indeed
backup local minimum for this problem
even when all the components are well
separated even when you have infinitely
many data points
so even at the population level
you have that local minimum whenever you
go beyond two components
and moreover these bad local minimums
they are real they are real in the sense
that if you run gradient descent from a
random initialization they will converge
to one of this bad local minimum
with high probability
and the probability becomes even higher
when the number of components becomes
larger
and in fact you can explicitly write
down
uh one of the such bad local minimum
which may be related to the uh earlier
question
so one that local minimum looks like
this so here i have data generated from
a mixture of four gaussians all these
gray points are data points
so about local minimum we put
two centers
in the middle of a single component
and the other center
in the middle of two components
and then i have put the remaining center
at the right position and the fourth
component
so this is a bad local minimum
um
is
like its objective value can be
arbitrary far away from
the true
global minimum and
as the number of components gets larger
you will see more and more this kind of
bad low convenience
and greatness and will come worse than
we have with high probability
but what we can show here is
uh
a result that is a little bit surprising
at least to ourselves
which is this is essentially the only
type of bad local minimum
or local minimum or bad local minimum
look like this
so in particular this is our theorem
which i don't expect you to read
i'll give you a
simple version of the informal version
of the theorem
so here i am
fitting a mixture of k
or k star components
and we can show that all the local
minimum of your
negative likelihood function
involves
only two types of configuration which we
call one bit many and many fit one
so one thing many means that
you put a center in the middle of
several components
so i have one
center corresponding to
multiple true centers
and magnified one means i put multiple
centers
i use multiple centers to fit a single
true components i have multiple centers
corresponding to a single
true centers
so all local minimum have this kind of
one too many or many to one
configurations
and the global minimum
which is the true centers is a special
case of this where i only have one
one to one correspondence
and any other kind of solution any other
configuration is not going to be a local
minimum for example if you use two
centers
to fit three
components
so i have a two fit
two to three correspondence between the
fitted centers and the true centers and
this is not
a local meaning
and we prove this by explicitly uh
provide a descent direction from this
solution
and similarly if you have used two
centers to fit two components like this
i have a two to two correspondence
then this is not a local minimum either
there is a descent direction
um so in words in this case even though
bad local minimum do exist
they have this hidden structure that
they all partially identify the true
sensors in the sense that we they either
identify the average
of multiple true centers
or they identify just one true center
and this results holds even when you
specify the number of components
so
suppose i'm fit i'm using a mixture of k
components to fit data that is generated
from a true mixture with k-star
components
and regardless of the value of k and
k-star the same result holds it holds
when k is bigger than k star which is
the over penetration setting
or k is less than k star which is the
under parenthesization setting
and this results also hold
if you replace the negative log likewise
function
with the k-means objectives which is a
non-smooth
objective function
the question uh what's the assumption on
the model for example this high snr
assumption what does it mean means the
separation
is large or it goes to infinity
um
great question um
so here by high snr i mean it is greater
than a large enough constant times some
function of k some function of the
number of components
so we do not
try we did not try to optimize the
dependence on k
um we did not try to
optimize the this snr condition but you
are absolutely right that and
for now
we need some assumption of the snr it
doesn't have to go to infinity
but it doesn't have the dependency okay
and where is sample size or this is an
infinite sample size result
um landscape
um so this is the input sample size
results but uh there are existing
technology that you can uh generalize
into finite example
for example using the paper that you
just mentioned by
by monteney
which shows that
as long as your sample size is is large
enough then
the final sample objective preserves the
landscape of the population objective
and it's a
very intriguing question that is to us
of
in terms of what happens if your sni is
smaller
so we don't have a complete answer we
have some observations
for example we can show that if your sni
is very small
then you don't have bad local minimum
i think some of your workers actually
prove that in some setting
the harder case is when the snr is in
the middle
when it's either too large
or not
or too small
then we are not clear what happens in
that case
hopefully that answers some of your
questions
and the next question that
some of you might have is uh
so what
now that i know the structure of the
local minimum
can you use
this results to guide the design of
better algorithms
so it's clear that in order to find the
global net minimum you cannot rely on
gradient descent or em themselves uh
because these are local minimum and
gradient design will converge to local
minimum so to ex to escape this bad
local minimum you need some idea that
that is beyond this local greedy uh
iterative output algorithm approach
and the high level idea is actually very
natural
since we know that all local minimum
have this one big many or many fit one
structures
then to avoid this local minimum you
just need to avoid these structures
and there are actually multiple ways you
can do this
for example
you can do smart initialization
for example since i want to avoid this
kind of magnified one putting multiple
centers
in the middle of a single component
can choose my initial sensors in a way
that they are far away from each other i
can just choose my initial centers to be
spread out so that it is unlikely that
you will put
multiple centers near the same
components and this is actually exactly
the idea that underlines the celebrated
king's prosperous algorithm
where they choose this initial sentence
in a proprietary way
that encourage them to be spread out
and you can take this idea one step
further um don't you don't have to stop
at the internalization you can use the
same idea
throughout the iteration
in particular you can use this so-called
there's a split and burst type of
procedure
where
within the iteration of your algorithm
if you see two centers that are very
close to each other then it is likely
that they are fit in the same center
then in that case you should merge them
and if you see a center that has a very
poor fit to the data
then it is likely that it is it is
fitting multiple true components
so in this case you probably you want to
split these centers into two say
perturb them a little bit
and then run k-means or e-m again
starting from that
algorithm and you repeat this procedure
and we actually test out this idea on
some benchmark data set and compare it
with the standard em or uh k-means
algorithm and we see quite
promising results
and finally um
another idea that
i find myself find very promising is
over parametrization
so in our primarization
i'll choose k which is the number of
components in my model
to be much larger
significantly larger than the number of
true components
and the idea is that once you have
enough center then it is unlikely that
you will have one bitmap
you will have enough centers to
fit each
true components individually so you
don't have this kind of one big many
configuration anymore
we are still working on uh understanding
the performance and behavior of over
current transition and i think
uh
some participants of this workshop
including our session share
uh have results on that
but
i'm going to just show you
a
numerical result
so here i have data points that are
generated from
three components three a mixture of
three gaussians
and i fill the model with many more
centers here i'm using
some like 30 centers
then then as you can see
when i run within this
run
em uh this variety center is actually
collapsed into the right number of
components which is three here
and moreover it avoids all the local
minimum solution that i prove exist
and converts to the global minimum
solution
and it turns out this phenomenon is
actually quite robust you can actually
choose the number of
centers to be equal to the number of
data points so we are doing this extreme
over quantization
and it seems that
uh
em or the k-means algorithm is still
going still able to find good solution
for example i can show you one plot
where i have a lot of centers
so here i'm choosing the number of
center to be equal to the number of data
points so the convergence behavior as
you can see is more complicated we have
this weird
phenomenon here that we
do not completely
understand yet but on a high level it
seems like
with over quantization we are still
collapsing into the right number of
components
so it is our ongoing work
to try to understand this phenomenon
more rigorously and i'm also
uh eager to see
the results from people who are also
working on this problem
all right so um this is a pretty much
all the technical results i want to
present today
and
i want to conclude my talk
uh
from a
bigger picture so here as i mentioned
we see a lot of hong kong's optimization
problem in machine learning and
statistics and hopefully
you can believe that this kind of
problem is not necessarily hard we have
seen example where all local minerals
actually go both this by
non-convexity for example in the in the
setting where you have a mixture of two
components
we see examples where bad local minimum
may exist
but they have this hidden structure that
actually
partially identified uh the global
minimum and you can take advantage of
these structures
to design algorithms that escape the bad
local minimum and find the good ones
so this and ratio more than k
more than three gaussians is an example
of this
and over quantization is one example
where a greedy method actually
is a bit is able to avoid the bad low
competing moment conversion group
and what i haven't talked about today is
uh commercialization fun long car's
problem there are many many work
on this in this direction
and finally
um sometimes you might want to use
non-smooth and non-comox formulation for
your problem and non-smoothness is not
necessarily worse or harder to solve
than the smooth
counterpart
and i want to highlight that all this
phenomenon
where
non-commerce optimization
is chartable and have all these hidden
structures it's not limited to just
mixture problems or clustering problems
we see this kind of phenomenon in a much
older range
of machine learning and statistic
problem that range from matrix
automation to
sparse regression
to pca
to
reinforcement learning
and to neural networks
and i hope that
by combining techniques from both
optimization
and statistical analysis we can have a
much better understanding of this kind
of long comments problem that arising
statistics and machine learning
all right so it seems that i can
uh
am i taller
chris
thanks for the talk
so uh
i guess the reason why people are
usually worried about using more centers
than there are clusters is that
they you know you'll over fit in the
sense of dividing one cluster into two
but if i understand what you're saying
this is a low dimensional phenomenon
right i mean if i actually do this with
let's say there's really only one
cluster
and let's suppose i'm literally in two
dimensions yes if i use two centers
you know then they'll somehow divide the
cluster into two halves between them two
semicircles and you see a little bit of
that at the bottom there
where there's a stream of centers which
are kind of trying to find something of
their own you know
uh moving out away from the center
so if if i understand what you're saying
in high dimension in the high
dimensional setting
this effect
largely goes away because the uh
well because for instance most of the
area or almost the volume of a sphere is
at its equator
in high dimensions and so these two
centers in one gaussian cluster
would tend to be
get closer and closer as the
dimension increases is is that the right
intuition
um certainly in a constant number of
dimensions
you would split clusters
if you had more centers
yeah so this is a great question
uh i want to start off uh by saying that
we haven't fully understood this
phenomenon yet
so here uh
i want to emphasize that it is important
to use the log likelihood formulation
here rather than the k-means formulation
for example if you are running k-means
and you choose and you use you try to
partition the data points into uh n
uh clusters so that your number of
centers equals to the number of data
points it won't work at all
because in that case you will just use
each of
each of your data point as a center
right
so this uh forward transaction will not
work if you are doing k
so this phenomenon is you only see this
in one phenomenon when you are using the
likelihood
formulation
only by doing that you will see this
collapse
of the centers
into the right number of components
and my second answer is uh
related to the specific question the the
specific example that you have where i
have a a single gaussian
and i'm trying to fit a mixture of two
gauss into it it turns out in that case
if you are looking at the negative log
likelihood objective
then
the best solution the global optimal
solution is to put these two sentences
at exactly the same place at the true
center you're not going to split your
components into two
so
what if you don't know the correct
variance for instance
well if i don't know the correct
variance then i'm not sure
but if you do yeah if you do know the
correct variance then the optimal
solution will be this would be to put
the two centers at exactly the same
place and this is different from k means
right if you run k-means
if you run two means
on a problem with only a single cluster
then you will divide that cluster into
two
so again this phenomenon seems to be
specific
it
seems to be tied to the objective
function that you use
so as you said as you said at the
beginning
k-means is the limit of the log
likelihood when we think the variance is
much much smaller
than it really is okay yes sir
it seems that having a non-zero
variance parameter have some kind of
regularization effect or
that encourage the centers to collapse
into each other and uh yehon have
something some amazing work in this
regard and i'm actually happy to hear
what
if he has anything to add
well i perhaps you meant the the
infinitely overprioritized
continuous mixture model yeah i mean
uh we only know what happened in one
dimensions
if you infinitely over parameterize with
high probability you will not fit more
than log n centers
so that was uh yeah that was what i know
and i have no idea what happens in
multiple dimensions
uh
yeah i mean maybe your structural
results will
share some new lights on this
sorry i don't have any
but there's another question from joe
sure
yeah hi you don't i was gonna ask a
question about the analysis i'm
wondering so i guess behind your main
theorem you must have some way of
characterizing where are all of even
just all of the critical points of your
model
um
i'm wondering if uh
if that's
true and is that characterization the
part that's like relying on this high
snr assumption
um
the second result right um
yeah that's right yep
um so
for this particular resource we are
actually only looking at
um
the
local minimum or critical points so we
use the information from both the
gradient
and
and the hessian
and our analysis goes like this
it basically says that if you have a
configuration like this
and
moving these two sensors away
from each other will strictly improve
the objective value of your problem and
i can prove this is true for any uh
configuration that is not magnified one
or one figment
i'm not sure if this analysis will say
anything about the other critical points
that are not local minimum
okay i guess my question is so my
experience with this kind of problem is
that even characterizing where the
gradient vanishes in a model like this
is
is this seems quite complicated for the
for the log likelihood so i'm wondering
okay you're saying that if you have a
configuration like this then you know
you can push them away but how do you
figure out that you want to look at a
configuration like this
uh in the first place or like where
would what what kinds of configurations
do you actually need to reason about at
a second order level
um
um
yeah sorry i don't i don't know if this
question makes sense but um
so is it fair to say nasus doesn't go
through computing the gradient and
hessian exactly but maybe some sort of
perturbation aren't even
i don't know if you heard you don't
squash us ask if the analysis goes
through by a perturbation argument or do
you compute exactly the gradient
measurement
so it's actually very
simple to write down the gradient
and the hessian and set it to zero
the question is when to show that when
the direction that i just proposed is
the decent direction and that is the
place where we use the high snr
uh assumption
and our
intuition actually comes from
the limit where your snr is infinitely
infinitely high
so that each of these
components is actually a single point
so in that case
if you have my true data point looks
like this just four points and you are
looking at
any
conflict any potential solution
for example that looks like this
and
and then you just follow the k-means
rule you assign uh each data point to
its closest center
uh like this
and if you whenever you see that there
is a
this kind of uh
if this data point is also assigned to a
different center like in here
so i have a two fit two situation here
meaning that these two
blue centers are fitting these two
red points
in this case you can ex you can
explicitly
construct a descent direction
by moving
these green points this
one of these
blue points to another center
and it turns out this uh
this argument can be generalized even
when your snr is not infinitely high
but is a finite number but it cannot but
it will break down if the snr is
uh very small i see i think i understand
what you're saying which is that in this
in the super high snr regime actually i
need each of my um
my points to sort of be equidistant from
some number of clusters in order for
that to satisfy some first order
condition otherwise there's just going
to be yes clear to exactly okay great
thanks yeah
yeah so
um
we've spent a lot of time trying to
think about
we have a generalization from this
k-means approach to
the locker approach
it turns out the only technical
difference you need to make is to
replace this hard assignment which we
did we do in k-means with this soft
assignment which we do in in em but you
can still define this kind of
correspondence between the centers
and
and the true components and you can
still explicitly demonstrate a descent
direction
given that your configuration is not one
big manual magnifique
any more questions or comments
okay if not let's thank we don't again
have a great talk
thanks thanks
everyone so we are reconvening in the
afternoon
at 2 p.m okay
see you later